and finally numeral now that we've had
Mother's Day and Father's Day let's set
aside this Sunday to celebrate people
who are neither with a new holiday
called I didn't reproduce day
I let me be clear I am NOT saying
there's anything wrong with having a
small number of children after all
children are the leaders of tomorrow
sometimes they're even the leaders of
today I'm just saying where's the
holiday for single people we don't have
a day only happy hour but we spent a
lifetime being the cool aunts and uncles
but while we celebrate everybody else
nobody ever celebrates us and they
really should because you know what
mother nature loves even more than
electric cars condoms there's literally
nothing you can do that's better for the
environment than to not produce another
resource sucking wastes making human
being probably with a bad attitude
I didn't bring a kid into the world to
consume valuable resources where's my
breakfast in bed where's my coupon good
for one foot rub
where's my greeting card that says roses
are red violets are blue you help the
earth by keeping a lid on your goop so
you know you can do it all you get the
hybrid car do the recycling not throwing
batteries in the trash it all adds up to
a fraction of the good it would do to
have just one less child because that
child increases your carbon legacy by
over 9,000 tons and remember every time
a single person does something to
prevent pregnancy they're creating more
slots on college campuses for your kid
Hallmark needs a card that says it's not
that you're gay it's not that you're
lesbian but because you didn't have kids
mine got into Wesleyan
[Applause]
[Music]
so you know having kids are not having
kids that there's not a moral dimension
to it that's what I'm saying it's just
your taste I don't have kids for the
same reason you do because that's what
each of us wants I get it
lots of people love kids although I must
say known in the world ever looks
happier than when Maury Povich says you
are not the father you are not you are
not you are not you are not
[Applause]
you know everyone is so used to married
with children being the norm that nobody
noticed that single people are actually
the majority now in August 2014 the
unmarried for the first time surpassed
the married in sheer numbers and yet you
know we still remain a somewhat suspect
group somehow incomplete whenever we're
at a party people always feel free to
tell us how good it would be to get
married to have a kid but somehow it's
rude if I say and you know what you guys
should totally get divorced
when you're childless people love to
tell you you have to have a baby but you
don't have to you have to have car
insurance remaining single isn't for
everyone but it's a perfectly rational
decision the science is in singles
exercise more than married people do
yeah
single women have better overall health
and men less heart disease singles
actually have stronger social ties let
debt and are more likely to volunteer
for civic organizations now of course a
lot of this is to get laid but not all
of it so stop asking a woman why she
isn't married or why she doesn't have
children she doesn't owe you an
explanation you owe her 9,000 tons of
carbon
and stop describing not being married as
shocking or surprising [ __ ] Jennifer
Aniston had to tell people magazine that
she's been shamed as a sad childless
human yes like she's the pathetic freak
as opposed to these pillars of the
community
the Duggars with their litter of 19
children you know call me anti family
but I say you're overdoing it when your
wife has to say not tonight honey I'm
giving birth